dimanche tranquille sur les plages ou
les gens de la capitale vont comme
toujours se reposer loin des tourments
politiques de la semaine
nous sommes prêts de mike et tia petite
ville tranquille à une heure de caracas
mais quand on s'approche des besoins
quotidiens des gens
la colère gronde il en soit l ami si la
survie au venezuela erika colline avant
des produits ménagers 7 jours sur 7
mon amour et luna elle doit travailler
dur si je veux y arriver le gouvernement
l'a aidé pour avoir sa boutique mais
c'est tout les détergents ou les
produits nettoyants de marque sont
introuvables ou trop chères comme tout
le reste
l'hyperinflation d'un million pour cent
en 2018 et le fmi prévoit un taux
surréaliste de 10 millions pour cent en
2009 tout le monde ici à des proches qui
sont réfugiés à l'étranger faute de
travail ou de salaire décent et locales
au tapis ou soir deux émissaires y avait
plus de 2 millions de vénézuéliens ont
quitté le pays depuis 2014
tout le monde dit que les richesses du
pays sont littéralement pillé les
économistes ont constaté une contraction
du produit intérieur brut de 45% depuis
et la situation ne fait qu'empirer
bah ouais
tout est cher les gens n'achètent plus
l'argent comptant d'évaluer et remplacé
par les cartes de débit
cette âme veut acheter un peu de viande
mais sa carte ne passe pas manque de
fonds
alors comment faire changer les choses
les cas précis
dénouement de la crise vénézuélienne et
aussi l'arrivée éventuelle d'un
humanitaire promise par wang wei d'eau
la situation économique ne peut
qu'empirer dans quelques semaines
l'embargo américain sur le pétrole va
frapper durement pas seulement le
gouvernement mais de l'eau mais aussi
forcément la population jean michel
leprince sera du canada mike et tia